voici une offre exceptionnelle qui
pourrait transformer votre grille
voulant prouver plus de ne rien entendre
qu'est-ce qui a dit améliorez votre
écoute dès maintenant voici le msa 30x
entièrement rechargeable un appareil
révolutionnaire munis de la toute
nouvelle technologie le msa 30x
révolutionnaire ces fonds nous disent le
médecin spécialiste et l'audiologiste
que nous avons consulté sa conception et
même de mauvaise qualité ce tte de
manière indépendante pour une acuité
auditive 30 fois supérieur à la normale
oubliez cela selon nos experts le msa 30
x offre une ratification légère et de
qualité de lydia cet appel également ce
volume de tous les bruits et en
augmentant de façon trop important des
fréquences au besoin d'être enrichi le m
et 130 x pouvaient aggraver votre perte
auditive
cet appareil est donc potentiellement
dangereuses améliorer votre écoute et
profiter de cette offre vous encourage
tous à l'essayer pour protéger le public
l'ordre des audioprothésistes du québec
a demandé mon grand réseau de télévision
de la province de retirer cette pub
tous ont accepté bref un message
publicitaire qui méritent qu'une chose
être passé sous silence